we all should be aware of every single
person who dies fighting for our freedom
and democracy around the world where
we're going
Sadr City over 2 million people lived
under a dictators boot for 24 years we
can build a better future for them for
the whole country that's why you know we
all live pretty comfortable lives and we
hear things on the news and especially
nowadays when it's such a sort of
swipeable to achieve all world so now
more than ever I think it's important to
tell these stories you know I think
everybody on this set actor wise has
approached their roles with a huge level
of humility and just gone I'm here in
service of this story I'm here in
service of these men and women read one
Comanche six find a secure defensive
position and wait for extraction we're
coming or effects everyone you know war
affects the soldiers that are there in
the trenches it affects their spouses it
affects their children and that is what
is so important I really think is that
it's not just the soldiers it's not just
a military who goes to war we all go to
war are you sure you're not worried
there's only been one incident in the
entire city in the last year we're not
even bringing the heavy armor if there's
a gun going off of there it's probably
there's some fool celebrating a Cowboys
game well it never hurts to be extra
sure I hope what audiences take away
from the series
is it these are your soldiers your
families this didn't just happen that
one time it still happens
[Music]
you